we've had many videos of characters
showing how much they're above the
competition but what about the other
side of the equation what about those
poor souls that have had to see that
power firsthand or in much more muted
scenarios what about someone who has an
astounding lead only to blow it due to
shenanigans or simply being outsmarted
that's what we're going through today
let's go through some of the most
embarrassing defeats in anime let's
start with regan versus 7th division
[Music]
entering the 12th episode suspense is
high with mob and the group seemingly
faced with unsurmountable odds by the
time the first few minutes were done it
was all over reagan stands up and let's
just say the seventh division stood no
chance whatsoever after taking mob's
power temporarily the battle against
ishiguro was nothing but a cake walk who
cares about those black holes when
reagan can easily nullify them gravity
attacks what a joke after some more
talking reagan ends it by throwing
ishiguro away and masking him in the
process and all the time our mentor he
remains completely chill as if he wasn't
even in a fight to the death just
seconds ago doubles as a mental flex and
being defeated like this with the
numbers game on their side it's gotta
hurt
for something more modern now how about
okin versus boss
oken seems to be taylor fit for the big
boss role he's intimidating he has a
penchant for violence and he's one who
relishes in suffering refusing to put
enemies out their misery this is it
truly the ultimate villain for the
heroes to face in a ranking of kings any
more than proved his worth in his
on-screen exploits nothing stood in his
way and i personally lost track of the
number of characters who'd fallen
against oaken even bodgie and the big
four weren't able to truly land a
decisive blow on him thanks to good old
villain regeneration he seemed
unstoppable and he's enjoying every
moment of it then boss comes back and
it's all over all those achievements and
feats in combat go down the drain and
ogan was dispatched like some random
small fry while oaken wouldn't be killed
he would be sealed trapped in a way to
prevent regeneration from demigod to
pathetic fodder real quick
[Applause]
luke valentine's first defeat against
alucard has to be up there
luke valentine sure talks big for a
mayan and villain yeah luke's not as
loud and obnoxious as his brother but
he's a big talker in his own right who
goes around claiming that he'll
single-handedly put down alucard after
all come on man apparently luke didn't
get the memo on arnold card's prowess
now did he well he got his chance to
test his powers out in their first
encounter unfortunately though for luke
he may have bit him way off more than he
could chew and the resulting fight is
not even close for all the talk he did
he decisively was no match for alucard
who turns the tide on his condescending
attitude this time it's alukar mocking
him for being useless and pathetic
before literally feeding him to the dogs
that's not the end of it all either but
let's face it with the pride that's
keeping him afloat gone luke's finished
i think a lot of you know it's coming
freeza vs trunks
[Applause]
[Music]
no it's not the equally embarrassing
defeat frieza had against goku the one
that sees him sliced by his own attack
in that one at least he more than
justified his status as arc villain he's
a legitimate threat and he was such a
powerful wall for our heroes to cross
this time it's different returning with
a newly enhanced body and vowing revenge
frieza runs into not goku but trunks
frieza wanted goku with no one else but
trunks proved to be more than a match
for him this time he was defeated with
little fanfare his attacks were thrown
back at him and he was easily
eviscerated by this mysterious fighter i
mean it wasn't even a match and i think
this kind of defeat is way more
humiliating than the one he suffered in
his own arc from arc villain to random
fodder even with a new body at all
frieza had one big fall from grace
i'm sure we've had these embarrassing
defeats ourselves right we don't battle
like anime characters do well yeah but
we sure lose out on some amazing deals
that we could have gotten that's where
today's video sponsor slick deals comes
into play sleek deals is the largest and
most trusted deal sharing company out
there thanks to their service people
have saved thousands of dollars in their
hunt for the best deals out there by
installing the slick deals browser
extension you can get the best prices
and discounts when you shop online it
allows you to compare sites with one
another in your hand to get the perfect
deal say goodbye to searching for
coupons or cashback points too slick
deals has that part down too and the
extension openly applies the latest
coupon codes now using it i was able to
get some deals on accessories like this
awesome gaming headset that i got for
half the price the best part about sleek
deals is that it also features an always
active ever growing community with over
12 million users sharing their
information you can easily get the best
deals available in real time if you're
ready to experience online shopping like
never before then be sure to try out
slick deals get the best prices for your
gaming accessories appliances and such
at your fingertips by downloading the
extension through this link in the
description luffy vs bellamy is quite
comedic honestly
why did i find this funny because better
be spent more time talking and bouncing
around and hitting luffy it's something
if this were a more contested and
intense battle but luffy and bellamy is
practically a joke of a fight yeah i
mean it is a joke despite what bellamy
would suggest otherwise bellamy does a
great job putting his techniques out
there he does a great job creating a
ruckus he talks big he talks loud and
gets quite obnoxious at some point one
thing he doesn't do a great job at as
you know is defeating luffy for all the
bragging he gets put down super easy and
i don't think there's anything more
damaging to your own pride than going
down like that having knuckle imprints
left on you is the finishing touch to
the embarrassment of being one shotted
just like that
however even more comedic is saitama
versus sonic
[Music]
racing after hammerhead a good friend
speeder sonic encounters none other than
saitama the stage is set for an epic
showdown one that will crush all of our
assumptions one that will
never mind hype up this showdown as much
as i want we all know what's gonna
happen don't we but the whole point of
one punch man is never in the pretend
suspense in saitama fights in fact this
fight turned out to be one of the most
entertaining fights in the entire first
season sonic goes all out from the
get-go only to have his pride hurt by
saitama seeing through those attacks
feeling more and more agitated sonic
starts talking himself up on how he'll
kill saitama only to be met with
indifference while he decides to finish
it off with his ultimate technique such
a move will only prove to be his undoing
when saitama responds with his signature
punch to the crotch now that's gotta
hurt bad also doubles as an extremely
comedic moment coming at the expense of
sonic's dignity
[Music]
we're all so used to villains being
humiliated but what about the
protagonists come on in subaru
of course it's subaru taking the fall
here then again he's just suffering
incarnate for most parts of re zero and
an important part of his development
involved him getting his ass kicked in
public it wasn't even a match at all and
julius just spends literal minutes on
end beating him down while everyone
watches on subaru may have kicked ass
the previous arc but it's all back to
earth for him in this one and the bad
news just keeps coming for him it's this
beat down that further drove a wedge
between him and emilia and the two
finally have their decisive conflict
right after this event kick-starting the
last arc of the first season hey it's my
favorite arc so i guess there's some
good to be had from this humiliating
defeat it's such a pivotal moment that
often gets lost in the shuffle because
we're all too enthralled with the whale
fight better gives his entire character
and rem's confession subaru sure had to
earn his happy ending for this arc and
it all started with a public humiliation
[Applause]
is another fight that i found amusing
naruto isn't exactly a match for kiba if
we're only to look at the first half of
the fight his techniques along with
akamaru proved to be too much for our
plucky protagonist and after the first
few moments of this tuning exam match
things look to be over for naruto who
gets forced to continually dodge a
decisive hit prompt kiba to start trash
talking but as people say pride comes
before the fall naruto's a strategy
however allows him to turn the tide
kibar tries to mount a comeback but he
eventually falls to naruto out shadow
cloning him giba had so many
opportunities to close out the match but
he got cocky i find it ironic he lost to
shadow clones when it was he who opened
with this version of that technique
[Music]
speaking of losing to your own technique
how about killua vs railvelt
[Applause]
heavens arena is memorable for a lot of
fights we have the whole gone versus
hisoka thing but often lost in the
footnotes is this minor confrontation
between killua and riovelt it's not too
long of a fight and it's not much of a
fight in the first place actually
honestly it's mostly just real well
sizing up kilowatt and attempting to
attack him with the outrageously named
twin snake whips the whole time
guillermo remained composed and simply
counted his adversary's attack
skillfully eventually rauvelt pulls out
all the stops and unveils his secret
technique thundersnake unfortunately for
him though kilowatt was unfazed by his
electricity but not him he gets caught
in his own technique and it was what
kilowatt uses to finish him off losing
to your own technique never feels good
especially not in front of spectators
right after you so proudly talked it up
okay oh this is still sticking off
finally it's isen beating everyone
[Music]
yes finishing off with one of my
personal memorable moments in shonen
aizen versus everyone can mean a lot of
things however while the whole troll
moment in kanakura town is a contender
you know after everyone unloaded on momo
of all people but i think that his
defeat of ichigo and orenji is something
else to be fair both ichigo and renji
had just been to hell and back with
stopping rookier's execution still the
anime pulled out all the stops to make
it seem like they had a chance to win at
all the wrapped up rng still had a bit
of fight left in him and he and ichigo
even cooked up an amazing plan to beat
aizen ichigo's theme plays they go at it
and eisen stops ichigo's sword with a
finger then proceeds to one shot both of
them the music ends and is literally
never heard of in the anime again at
least that version of number one it's
not ichigo's first defeat against a
tough foe but this was a time when he
just received such a big spike in power
coming off a win against byakuya
momentum is completely at his side and
boom
that's it for my list most embarrassing
defeats in anime for me these are my
favorites still i'm actually interested
in your opinion on the worst and most
embarrassing defeats so do make sure you
keep those comments coming in on that
and don't forget to check out our
sponsors slick deal for the best deals
and discounts while shopping online you
can download the extension by using the
link in the description i hope you can
also come over to videotube's other
social media channels as well discord
instagram and patreon are all available
in the description box as usual like and
subscribe if you like what you're seeing
and i'd love to see you again for the
next video thank you and see you next
time